il est dit que lorsque le temps sera
venu pour les toits dan de transmettre
ctp aux humains elle ne parlera cas
celui qui deviendra un jour roi des
elfes devrais-je mallié un homme qui
veut renverser son suzerain
non vous devez suivre celui qui veut
libérer le roi du druide à beckton le
roi est fatigué après 101 bertholle
contrôler seuls nos troupes et les
envois délibérément au massacre
enrouler un millier de guerriers
supplémentaire est attaqué c'est mon
10500 atteindre tu te souviens du garçon
avec la marque dont je t'avais parler il
avait un pouvoir sur la nature si on le
retrouve il nous aidera battra bertone
j'en suis sûr
après si arte faen
l'heure d'affronter les ténèbres
approche à grande vitesse c'est pour
cela que l'épée s'est adressé à toi et
kate a conduits jusqu'à mon repère
traque l'oeil massa club